you're hearing starting to go did you
know that what seriously you're hearing
sorry cuz in the morning I always say
something you and you always go to me
what what do you 15 miles back no I'm
told that when I'm face to face with you
out by the car I go hey Ronnie I told
you about the weather yeah and you
always go what what what what huh that's
a habit is it yeah yeah because you know
what I think it is I think you do hear
me you just want maybe not always
I think you do know I don't know what
you do and you don't annoy me either
okay but I go I don't hear you but most
times I hear you yeah but I make like
you know I make like them then why do
you make me repeat everything twice is
that a control thing I don't know no he
heard me and not always I got oh hey Ron
you know I can't believe how warm it is
today and I'll go what yeah but I'm like
face-to-face with her yeah and then I go
I can't believe how warm it is well yeah
you know and then you'll talk but
everything is twice with him control I
remember going it's weird like when I
know when I'm angry with somebody I
always go what you know like I'm angry
with somebody I don't I don't answer at
all I just don't [ __ ] talk yes so why
if you heard me do you have to say what
I don't know it's a habit I think but
why do you make me go through that every
eating
I'm just told you why maybe it's a habit
no but it's a way of like controlling me
or something I'm not controlling you are
you making me repeat all right it's like
I like people who slow down when I'm
walking across the crosswalk yes yeah
[ __ ] yeah every time I talk to you
you're like what what hey loser but I
don't think he is I know man this
morning damage am i right here is that
true
I lost a little bit of hearing yes yes I
went for a hearing test a couple years
ago because I had this incident I went
to a race at Homestead yeah and I was in
the pits the whole time
and he's supposed to wear the headphones
and all that yours and I want to be a
big shot I didn't wear the headphone and
by the time the end of the race
compliment I couldn't hear Wow how it's
super loud for three days oh why you put
you look cooler without that no was just
like it do were annoying me and I didn't
want to be really laughing I went to a
hearing got you know to a doctor and I
got a [ __ ] hearing everything and I
lost her hearing aid if they told you
how to well yeah the new ones now you
don't but it's a cochlear implant they
can just do an edit put him right in
yeah Shirley what's so funny about me
it's funny yeah I would deal with his
races he he really he has to be mr.
nascar like these but sure yeah what's
around the bits and at what point we
were promised to be able to go sit on
top of what are the semi trucks to watch
the race where the racers were and the
woman apparently didn't get that memo
she asked us to move to a different area
he was so [ __ ] mad yeah because like
a little kid he's like we're supposed to
be on top of that whole [ __ ] we were
it was [ __ ] hey I'm the Big Shot
here no we were we were don't you know
who told you it wasn't as all it was his
pit box okay